- [Instructor] A cesarean section,
often referred to as a C-section,
is a surgical procedure
in which incisions are made
in a woman's abdomen and
uterus to deliver a baby.
Some cesarean sections are planned.
More often, however,
the need for the
procedure becomes apparent
after the onset of labor,
when abnormal conditions make
a vaginal delivery unsafe
for the mother or her baby.
Common indications for
cesarean section include
dystocia, placenta previa
and fetal distress.
Dystocia or prolonged,
non-progressive labor can occur
when the baby's head is unable to fit
through the birth canal
or its body is in an unfavorable position,
such as perpendicular to the
birth canal or buttocks first,
which is the breech position.
Placenta previa occurs when a
low-lying placenta partially
or completely blocks the cervical opening.
Fetal distress occurs
whenever the health of the
baby is in imminent danger,
usually from inadequate blood flow
through the placenta or umbilical cord.
Fetal distress can occur
when the placenta separates
from the wall of the
uterus prior to delivery
or the umbilical cord becomes
compressed or squeezed.
Other conditions that may
require a cesarean section
include multiple births,
large tumors of the uterus,
genital herpes or other
infections, or medical problems
such as uncontrolled
diabetes or hypertension.
Your doctor may use ultrasound testing
and a fetal heart monitor to help decide
whether your baby should
be delivered by cesarean.
When a cesarean section becomes necessary,
you will be prepped for surgery.
If not already in place,
an intravenous line will be started,
and a catheter will be inserted
into your bladder to drain urine.
In the operating room, you
will be given anesthesia.
In most cases, a spinal
anesthetic is administered
to numb the lower portion of your body.
Sometimes, however, a general
anesthetic will be used.
Your doctor will begin
by making an incision in your abdomen.
It will either be a vertical incision
from just below the navel to
the top of the pubic bone,
or more frequently, a horizontal incision
across and just above the pubic bone.
This is often called a bikini cut.
Your doctor will then
make a second incision
on the lower part of the uterus.
Once the uterus has opened,
your doctor will rupture the amniotic sac
if it is still intact
and deliver the baby.
The time from the initial
abdominal incision
to birth is typically five minutes.
Your doctor will then clamp
and cut the umbilical cord,
gently remove the placenta,
and tightly suture your
uterus and abdomen.
This typically takes about 45 minutes.
The hospital stay after a cesarean section
is usually three to five days.
During this time you will be encouraged
to breastfeed, nap when the baby sleeps,
and get out of bed often.
While most patients are able
to take care of their new
baby soon after the procedure,
full recovery may take six to eight weeks.
Your scar will lighten as it heals.
(upbeat synthesizer music)